Everyone who's anyone in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe showed up for the final fight in
Avengers: Endgame including one character
you most likely didn't spot.
Several eagle-eyed fans discovered that none
other than Howard the Duck makes a cameo appearance
during Endgame's climax.
"No one laughs at a master of quack fu!"
Well, not exactly THAT one.
This one.
The anthropomorphic duck pops up after Doctor
Strange, Wong, and dozens of other mystic
sorcerers open up portals for the heroes who
were dusted in Avengers: Endgame to step through
and join the battle against Thanos, his sinister
Black Order minions, his alien army, and his
massive ship.
Howard isn't easily located in Endgame's final
fight if you don't know where to look for
him.
Right as Hope van Dyne steps into frame, Howard
can be seen on the lower-right side of the
screen, passing through the portal as part
of a group that includes several members of
the Guardians of the Galaxy series' Ravagers,
coming to Earth to settle an interstellar
score with Thanos.
If you blink, you'll miss him and a lot of
people did.
Howard's cameo in Avengers: Endgame raises
a big question: Was he among the people decimated
when Thanos snapped his fingers at the end
of Infinity War?
Or did he manage to survive the Mad Titan's
mass-murder?
Apparently, Howard the Duck was one of the
lucky individuals in the universe who were
spared, with Joe and Anthony Russo confirming
to The Huffington Post that, quote, "he survived."
Created by writer Steve Gerber and artist
Val Mayerik, Howard the Duck is a self-styled
master of martial arts who has an undefined
grasp on magic.
Despite those limited abilities he claims
to possess, as well as the frequency with
which he's pal'd around with Marvel's mightiest,
he's rarely shown as possessing any typical
superhero powers.
This is different when he suits up as the
Iron Duck, gaining superhuman durability and
strength, as well as a flamethrower on each
arm.
However, Howard is just Howard in Endgame
so we can't say for certain how helpful he
might have been in the fight.
Fans first saw Howard in the MCU in 2014's
Guardians of the Galaxy, in which he appeared
as a living part of the Collector's museum,
alongside fellow easter egg Cosmo the Spacedog.
"What do you let it lick you like that for?
Gross."
Seth Green provided the voice for the CGI
character, then again lent his voice to Howard
for 2017's Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2.
In that film, Howard was seen having yet another
drink — this time on the icy planet Contraxia
while flirting with a woman.
"You know what they say — you're out of
luck until you've gone duck!"
These appearances in the Guardians franchise
were reportedly intended to lead to a part
for Howard the Duck in Infinity War.
But sadly, the cameo never happened.
Speaking in an interview with Fandom, Anthony
Russo explained,
"Howard the Duck was in one draft of the script.
Howard the Duck actually had a really good
scene.
[...] We were going to cameo Ken Jeong, with
Howard the Duck.
That was a much-beloved scene by us but it
just didn't end up fitting at all."
According to Joe Russo,
"[The scene involved Peter] Quill trying to
track down some information from Howard the
Duck on some outlier planet and interrupting
him during a poker game."
Though neither Howard the Duck nor Ken Jeong
made it to Infinity War, they both had some
screen time in Endgame.
Howard showed up at the tail end of the movie,
while Jeong made a cameo early on, playing
the security guard who helped Scott Lang get
out of the storage facility in San Francisco.
For a while now, there have been whisperings
of the possibility of a new Howard the Duck
movie, which would mark the second film based
on the wise-cracking duck after his 1986 debut.
Back in 2017, Marvel Studios president Kevin
Feige teased a future for Howard in the MCU,
saying,
"You know, the fun thing about Howard is he
shows up where you least expect him.
[...] Who knows where he's going to appear
next?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.